hello and welcome to this video I'm a
court I'm playing from Austria to
Austrians in a row okay 9006 yeah okay
this lion gains a little bit and
strength after indeed the two nights
should I to g7 bhai there's no tactic
here or something that looks a little
bit if y'all have seven but it doesn't
seem to be the case hmm ok I just
prevent we should reform
yeah maybe just Bishop f5 okay no Bishop
f5 that move probably was hard to solve
it for my opponent h5 yeah maybe it's
worried that I would move the night
somehow and put a green down wow if I go
night if five here takes Queen takes is
a double attack again on the rock and
the bishop Brooke age five maybe ok now
g5
yeah but ultimately this just costs
enormous amount of time and at the end
I'm not playing it Bishop d 695 this is
may be interesting but after a cremeux
if it's not clear that what this has
accomplished
yeah 95 is just a pretty pretty awful
short move and maybe 95 is actually good
I wasn't showing him
hmm
yeah it's not let's not idea really I
know Quincy 7 oh my god I have to stop
the session I really the the game before
that already was ridiculous okay whoo
Quincy seven threatening on f4
threatening on c2 and I resign it was
very lucky he has g2 now just but now
maybe I question every captured action
g2 is far more complicated than then
what he overlooked but does this is he
sees him ah what a terrible game
yeah just isn't any good IAM any good
square for the night not really i know
maybe maybe try to play this ending
check I have some fortress opportunities
maybe and ascending if he trades rooks
it's that is but she doesn't which is
the correct choice of course not to
trade
I the three that's the route to be one
ok so he wants to go to f5 I guess
time warning wait there what a great
game I really enjoy playing this oh my
god
it's really demo for check
your voice is probably good no I didn't
didn't see that this was a possibility
not that it is sold so terrible I just
didn't see it at all I cannot stop the
Shang rook e8 check the most subtle
trick ever check
Jack White resigns yeah it was just
total crap I'm sorry oh my god yeah and
I really did that that's really after
age 5 h for you shouldn't lose any
actually anyway yeah I didn't I didn't
really do much against this looks
terrible hy which one what's the point
of this stuff I mean you should develop
pieces at one point yeah but it doesn't
really matter he wanders a 4c for us
what the computer suggests probably I'm
just playing this too lame that's
probably all too lame and here black is
fine of what was already on that I have
to do with something immediately after
this h4 h5 off a4a seafoam and this just
loses the house which you didn't seem ID
I should probably take with the airport
that's pretty awful this is also pretty
awful yeah so how do I refute this stuff
h5 h4 I mean it's just like what yeah
this is what the computer wants to do a
five just push black around yeah
probably makes long castles difficult
even though that that looks dangerous
have to say the computers computer is
completely relaxed here but I don't know
yeah maybe h3 is also i mean it's not a
necessary
of course this cell cannot do this
probably or can you yeah he probably can
yeah this is this is not all that great
now okay I just didn't play it well and
he did what he had to do him hmm okay i
mean i don't know this know this stuff
really well i don't but ok guys end of
session thanks for watching